ما ستفعله هو أنه من المفترض أن
يعمل جهاز Roomba لديك مع Alexa، هل يمكنك أن تطلب من جهاز Roomba
أن ينظف أسفل طاولة المطبخ، ولكن من كان
يعلم أن جهاز Roomba يمكنه قلب الطاولات عن طريق
الاختفاء، لم نتمكن من العثور عليه
ونظرنا تحت كل الأثاث
دون علم أحد سكان جورجيا
توجه شيلي بيتس رومبا إلى الباب الأمامي الذي
تركوه مفتوحًا وكنا نقوم بعمل زينة عيد الميلاد
داخل وخارج المنزل وهرب بعد
يومين، وجده زوج شيلي
تحت مجموعة من أوراق الشجر إلى أي مدى
وصل حقًا إلى الصدق، ولم
يحصل عليه  على مسافة بعيدة جدًا ربما 10 ياردات، بعد أن
عثروا عليه، نظروا إلى
الكاميرا الحلقية الخاصة بهم وشهدوا
هروبه وكنا نضحك بشكل هستيري، فهل
كان الإنترنت هو جهاز Roomba الصغير الذي
يمكنه الآن أن يكون مهربًا نظيفًا
ولكن جهاز Roomba كان في حالة من الفوضى فقد فقد جهازه
الحشو وفرشه على الرغم من أنه لا يزال
يعمل، إلا أنه قام بعمله، كما تعلم أنه كان
يفعل ما ولد من أجل القيام به، لذلك قامت
بتحية The Runaway Roomba's Escape
بإضافة أغنية جورج مايكل
الكلاسيكية بدون Roomba، وقد
تركت العائلة في
فراغ شيموس سي إن إن نيويورك